a u.s marine officer who recently became
known by the public for his criticisms
of washington's handling of the
afghanistan pullout has been sent to a
military prison
lieutenant colonel stuart sheller jr is
currently in pre-trial confinement the
time date and location of the
proceedings have not been determined
lieutenant colonel scheller will be
afforded all due process
what stuart sheller did has polarized
many americans because there are those
who believe that he is a hero that he
stood up
and spoke out for what he believes
and that is a view shared by many
americans that the end of the afghan war
the evacuation that we saw at the end of
august was humiliating for the united
states that it was chaotic that it cost
the lives of too many american
servicemen and that it could have been
avoided if intelligence had been heeded
others believe that he spoke out of turn
that he should have addressed his
grievances through proper channels but
he himself says that
after 17 years in the military that he
could no longer stay silent that he knew
one of the 13
american servicemen that were killed in
an isis k
terror attack on the 26th of august at
kabul airport and that he must that he
had to speak out against the
incompetence of senior pentagon
leadership
people are upset because their senior
leaders let them down and none of them
are raising their hands and accepting
accountability or saying we messed this
up i'm not saying we've got to be in the
in afghanistan forever but i am saying
did any of you throw your rank on the
table and say hey it's a bad idea to
evacuate bagram airfield the strategic
air barriers before we evacuate everyone
i am submitting charges against general
mckenzie for his bad assumptions not
because i'm vindictive but because the
senior leaders need to be held
accountable to the same standard as us
essentially what stuart sherlock wants
is accountability he says that he has
always been held responsible for those
under him and so much senior pentagon
leadership uh be held accountable for
those under them including the 13
american troops
killed in the terror attack by isis k on
the 26th of august
at the airport of kabul however when he
went public he violated all manner of
protocols and codes of the u.s military
because
officers
and servicemen are forbidden from
publicly criticizing their superior
officers as well as speaking with
contempt of civilian leadership both of
which he did he was also issued a gag
order which he uh willingly violated
and which was evidently the final straw
for the military they arrested him and
threw him in a military prison for his
parents that was an act of courage
all our son did is ask the questions
that everybody was asking themselves but
they were too scared to speak out loud
he was asking for accountability in fact
i think he even asked for an apology
that we made mistakes but they couldn't
do that which is mind-blowing
there has been little by way of
accountability no one has been fired or
resigned either at the white house in
the uh biden administration or at the
pentagon over what many americans see as
a fiasco uh the final days of american
presence here in afghanistan
nevertheless what we have seen is
continued hearings continued grilling by
especially republic republicans but as
well as
as well as veterans who have criticized
the biden administration which has been
uh on the defensive with excuses after
excuses retaining bagram would have
required putting as many as 5 000 u.s
troops in harm's way just to operate and
defend it
the distance from kabul also rendered
bagram of little value in the evacuation
staying at bagram even for
counterterrorism purposes meant staying
at war in afghanistan
something that the president made clear
that he would not do
for now mr sheller who after 17 years of
service he he walked away from a 2
million dollar pension and he has handed
in his resignation uh he has also been
relieved of command but he remains an
active serviceman as these resignations
can take a while to go through
and for discharge to officially be
confirmed he remains in detention uh
pre-trial detention and awaits to most
likely face
military charges
you